right well first of all Morgan either I
mean when you are the leader of a
country I think you've got to be the
leader of the whole country so you can't
take a narrow view of you can't save
look at this my whatever the policy is
my church overrides you know the policy
that I think is in the interest of the
country though I think the difficult
thing here is that that actually your
religious views always of course color
your approach to many problems and
probably I would not have taken the same
attitude to the debt campaign if it
hadn't personally been involved in that
church movement and but that doesn't
mean it but what you can't do is then
surrender your you know your your as it
were your duty to do what you actually
think is right and represent the whole
country to your religion now people
always think religious people may do
that but actually genuinely they're
usually they don't in fact when the
governor out thing was Al Smith it was
the first Catholic ever the standards of
presidential candidate when he ran for
her office I think because the end of
twenties I think maybe but anyway there
was this big big campaign that the Pope
was gonna move opposite the White House
and you know he was there for and I
remember because my wife is a Catholic
before the 1997 campaign the Reverend
Ian Paisley suggested that my map
because my wife's allegiance was to Rome
then she couldn't you know I wouldn't
really be fit to around the country and
I'm proud same pamelor Rome was her she
got some Italian connection I don't know
about but actually when it members yeah
so I think you're gonna be careful of
that and the reason and the reason yeah
the reason frankly I didn't convert to
Catholicism when I was Prime Minister
was just look I had enough issues
without lighting that one it all the
earth so I decided to do it afterwards
but i think you know as a political
leader you've got to represent in a
pluralist society you've got to be able
genuinely to
then the whole of the country I think in
relation to what Joel was saying them
and I'm not sure about this actually I I
think there are overlapping principles
because i think you know both the lady
with the placard and barney frank kind
of except that in the end they're both
part of the constitution i think one of
the real strengths of america is this
idea that there is indeed a common space
that everyone is is it i mean one of the
things you find really interesting out
in the middle east is when you explain
to people in certain countries in the
Middle East that as a Muslim you can
worship in America because be watching I
thought people say to me nah no not an
American you say no say no millions of
Muslims you got lost in America now it's
and it's really you know I think but
that's because actually it's just taken
for granted really that this is that in
fact these principle do overlap even
with the most extreme people and I think
that's a very very important part of a
functioning Society very very important
part and not to be given up lightly at
all it's something that's desperately
important i was explaining to be
blurrier today how one of the issues i
had to tackle when I was Prime Minister
was that there was second generation
immigrants who would come into the UK
and decide that they would and could
still couldn't speak English second
generation and my view in the end was
that actually they had it was part of
their social obligation to do this
because otherwise we won't guess of as a
society now a one-level that's an
interference with someone's freedom but
in another level you need to create that
common space and you're right also that
it evolves over time of course it does
this is why any religious belief
actually that is static in other words
takes no account of its historical
setting is so I'm afraid wrong in the
end I mean it's just because timer vols
you know in Christian times there were
slaves some Paul wrote and about slaves
having to you know obviously to accept
the authority of their masters now that
there's a discourse there they were not
time would become
consider completely absurd and
unacceptable but that's the way it is
but I think the the value of having this
concept of the common space is that
allows that evolution to happen and for
that space also to be enlarged and
changed over time and a mantle just
finally on your bunker Stephanie you
were asking yeah you were asking to Nick
well I think if the state could make
that provision no I think that the
religious groups wouldn't have to fill
the gap but I think what's fascinating
and important is that they have filled
the gap and they filled it because
people were inspired by their religious
belief and that's why I think that that
that this as I say I think the
interesting thing about this whole
debate is that it's often put in terms
of religious people must accept that
they can't decide what happens as it
were just by virtue of their belief but
in actual fact I think every bit is
interesting which is the reason why
Nicholas roadies responds to a lot of
what was there is that the also people
who are non-religious should be open
enough to the religious to accept that
there are certain ideas and and thoughts
and values that that that actually can
enrich society as a result of that
religious belief even if you decide I'm
not a person of faith myself let's let
the other questions get raised just just
one quick response to what Tony said the
fact that the Muslims in the Middle East
find it incredible there but when you
say to them that as a Muslim you can
worship in the u.s. that just reinforces
the analysis I gave that that the way we
have structured religion in the state is
truly extraordinary and most people find
it difficult to believe what what do you
mean that that all the religions are
treated equally what that's extremely
difficult to believe and we forget what
a risky experiment it was 250 years ago
never never been tried and and I think
what's behind the
quotation is I mean how r watson and and
McIntyre also think of the state is just
like a telephone company and so forth a
huge bureaucracy but it's it's this
mistell Jaquan for once upon a time the
state was the highest expression of a
morally religiously unified citizenry
and now now that's gone and it's just
into management that's the nostalgia
that's that's putting it from the dark
frightening side but James Madison was
above all said it has to be tried